welcome
[Music]
I have a food from the Backson
help me put this on please whooping uh
okay
[Music]
we're getting your hair
Saudi Arabia
this is a story about Saudi people not
Saudi politics today we're going on a
mega road trip through the mountains of
the southwest corner of Saudi Arabia I
found some random windy road on Google
Maps it looks interesting and then down
down down so we're at 7500 feet now torn
roughly 2,300 meters down to G's on
which is on the Red Sea coast
help me put this on please
how do I hear oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's what I didn't have the extra
pole-vaulter ah okay
a baby honey we go Selina was born I
would ha
no but pizza
shook it on how much better
king house king house okay shook it on
there looks like a palace there has to
be some beautiful landscaping of
vegetation in there and I think this is
as far as temperatures go the coolest
part of the country we're gonna go down
here there's a windy road where is it
there it is I think that's the road
through this valley and out towards the
Red Sea this wood is so rugged weathered
hard yeah I don't think it comes as a
surprise to anybody that Saudi Arabia is
an arid dry rugged place so just getting
a little bit of greenery like this does
absolute wonders for the mind I'd say
Salaam one thing I don't get about so
much of the world is the whole trash
thing especially when they're all these
trash cans around doesn't make any sense
to me there's a can right there but
that's how it goes if your father if
your father threw the bottle on the
ground most likely you're gonna throw
the bottle on the ground
that's how humanity works for the most
part habits get passed on you either
learn
from your parents and you emulate them
or you learn you look at what they do it
and you you do the exact opposite
this is called Raja Heritage Village if
you want to be in a country where there
are absolutely zero tourists I don't
think you can beat Saudi Arabia on that
front
[Music]
shukran shukran DeLand
I'm from Yemen it reminds me of that art
area I went yesterday when there wasn't
one person there
they're drinking the green cancer here
that stuff used to make my teeth hurt I
used to be addicted to Mountain Dew
which is terrible
it's like antifreeze looks like people
are living up here this old village some
of the buildings well that one's been
redone some of them are broken falling
apart others have been redone
my boy Ali's setting things up here
setting it right it's getting really hot
out so this is the way to do it right
shook it on we're kissing we're blowing
kisses do something something right in
the Saudi government took control of
this town 100 years ago right 89 years
ago okay and the wind that make America
fall because by the minute ready give
him back on right
do that again all those those are shops
to sell a lot of things how long ago
were people living here
fifty years ago
they're moving ABBA that's where I came
from here it's interesting these new
city lights in here okay how old this is
this town you have a lot of snake people
live in these now no cool Arabian takers
and a lot of baboons do you like do you
like the baboons vicious they're vicious
aren't they yeah people think you're
cute did they think they're cute nice
for the kids for everybody monkey found
you know they will attack you
they'll rip your face
oh yeah it's my mud floor they're making
those floors my mixed mode and okay
Manas bad I'm not a big fan of bad Peter
his food from the baths this is
traditional this through you can see the
bats are you blessing me what's going on
yeah thank you
this is that really hardwood from up on
the mountain right yeah if we think we
wound up in this village the built the
house or something
mm-hmm this was here yeah how many years
ago 48 yeah so what's happening people
are moving out to set jobs right on the
school
couldn't sure mr. Pete like living room
[Laughter]
yeah okay
so where are you taking me I like your
road it's quite steep
actually that's not scope from the gift
from paper thank you well I live in
Ukraine bro and you always have to if
you enter someone's home you have to
bring a gift it's a very cool tradition
nice place yeah this is cool G T's great
this is this is your brother
yeah okay what's your name Ahmed Peter
yeah yeah thank you
what's in here this oh this is your
house I thought that was your house this
is your place you live alone or your
brother lives in here - Rosel it was a
center point for trade right from
Djibouti you were saying yeah
Djibouti and Sudan I'm a Cuba I'm from
Yama I love the look of the Arabic
language so beautiful actually not this
is not Arabic what is it
Manik thank you Jesus this one this can
you read this
that's a nice view great view Wow what
kind of snake amazing
this is how you make your coffee here
I was lucky to meet epitome alley fatty
right when I was leaving because there
were no English speakers and he gave me
the tappet or that I like I think you
guys like that too right going into
different different zones different
areas adventurous shukran this one
Mahad marca Suraj
Habibi you betcha
[Laughter]
you are saying a wedding here cost how
much $5,000 so it's difficult you face
out yes three times you must
based out your face it's relaxing okay
take it that would that I just smoked
was like very light it sort of like what
marijuana used to be before it got all
scientific and super powerful
at least from my experiences in
California recently
Salam alaikum okay these are live
yeah haha right yes
in India
nice to meet you where are we going
toilets right toilet okay you know this
stuff
no burning fire
yeah really good I do someone is from
Kerala India who to the nicer parts of
the country a lot of Indians here huh
are you many Indians yeah did the
toilets not in the restaurant it's down
here right okay
ya know
quite a mission for the toilet
Mercedes next Mercedes truck Hey Oh
toilet okay fantastic
proper feast Pepsi no water waters back
this looks like a traditional Saudi meal
Saudis let us know in the comments what
this is it looks good
I scored [ __ ] yeah so good
so bad
and then doing that fast-food [ __ ]
just because I couldn't find places he's
doing
cool thing about the open road like a
day like today you have that skeleton
root but you don't know what you're
gonna go into you don't know what to
expect you know what you're gonna eat
who you're gonna meet what you're gonna
see love this stuff and so the theme
running through the day is friendly
people cool people hospitality you know
what people say the curse of knowledge
and what I mean by that is what do you
know something you think it's common
knowledge
and Saudi Arabia to me the first date
didn't know I'm a thing nothing zero I
mean except from what I heard from the
outside right but as far as like how it
felt on the ground no understanding now
what is it Dave five acclimated to it
and so the curse of knowledge is you
know once you once you've done it in
experience too
you think it's just you know it's normal
[ __ ] I don't even know right now at this
point in time if this even looks out of
place it's even looks that much
different because I'm
I'm here if this makes any sense at all
but you know what I'm talking about like
when you when you speak when you know
something when you learn something and
they're like oh yeah I know that now and
then it just becomes common
Saudi Arabia is not there yeah for sure
like on the macro no way this place is
so complex this place is so mixed up I
mean I've had conversations that I
couldn't bring the camera out right and
but I've heard everything from people
telling me you know alcohol will be
legal in a couple years more a year I
think it was told to someone I just met
saying he thinks it's terrible that
woman are allowed to drive now
and this is because he says he respects
woman it wants to look after her
spectrum is massive here it's all over
the place
there are a lot of social codes here and
I don't really know them all to be
honest if you can seem to like this
though they get a kick out of it
now obviously I'm not fitting in with
this I don't look like anyone from here
but more than that it's it's cool to
play with identity it's cool to wear
this is call it a different costume
right identify myself differently being
a completely different culture and
country operate outside of my language
well let's just call it get by outside
of my language
it really it really had said like that
adventure I think it's not for everyone
right but that adventure we all long for
you can find it at this time of travel
you can find it in the unknown the
predictable shed is great for many
things that we all want safety and
security fact
but zagging the other way from time to
time where I find this is a balance I
got my rent-a-car know where I'm going
got a hotel room tonight roads are good
it's not that crazy but the interactions
throughout the day along the room there
surprises they're magical
I didn't have one bad experience today I
really feel that you the world is
universal in that sense is if you if you
just God with an open mind and open
heart people are warm
that's it guys end of an epic Saudi road
trip here in geez anon the Red Sea coast
gonna try to get out to an island
tomorrow I heard there's an island out
here to explore so I'm gonna try to make
that happen
so thanks for coming along I am really
excited for this this is amazing I think
it costs like $45 tonight and air
conditioning it is very very hot outside
so until tomorrow peace do you like the
baboons
vicious